a face mask is projected and the statue
of christ the redeemer
the symbol of rio de janeiro it's a call
for awareness as the number of
coronavirus
cases keep rising across brazil
yet president jaime bolsonaro who has
been mocking the disease from the start
keeps hugging and shaking hands with
allies and supporters
on sunday he once again led a protest in
the capital brasilia
against stay-at-home measures ordered by
local governors
as he fights against accusation of
corruption from the country's congress
and supreme court
[Applause]
we want the true independence of the
three powers not only a fraction of the
constitution
we don't want that enough with
interference we won't admit
any more interference i'm being very
clear patience has run out
last week bolsonaro replaced the
country's most popular anti-corruption
crusader
former justice minister sergio moro who
now accuses him of trying to meddle in
police investigations against
him and his sons but while the president
is focused on his political problems
the virus is spreading rapidly in the
amazon state capital manaus
health services have been overwhelmed by
the number of sick people
the city is handling more than a hundred
deaths per day
three times the normal average as
authorities dig mass graves to bury the
dead
the mayor of manaus made an
international plea for help
as concerns grows that the virus could
have devastating effects
on the amazon's vulnerable indigenous
tribes
i'm telling you that
we are needing help we have to save
the lives of the protectors of the
florida
from coronavids
we are in front of a disaster
something like barbarism
a call for help that so far has rung
hollow
for a president whose critics say seems
more worried about political survival
than keeping brazilians alive alison
rampieti al jazeera